[Musique]
gorgone multicanaux dans le nord-est de
l'italie
il est presque dix heures du soir daniel
et graziano commencent leur ronde sur
toute la commune
ce sont des sympathisants de la ligue du
nord comme 98 % des habitants du village
c'est le camino
on essaie de protéger le territoire de
protéger la sécurité des citoyens en
faisant des rondes
si on voit des mouvements bizarres
quelqu'un qui essaye de s'introduire
dans une maison on intervient en
appelant la gendarmerie ces citoyens
bénévoles sortent tous les soirs par
équipe de deux pendant trois heures ils
quadrillent le territoire go et
dangereuse or go est un village assez
tranquille sans problème particulier
on sait que nos immigrés ne font rien de
mal
ils sont sans histoire mais ces derniers
jours il ya eu des étrangers qui sont
arrivés dans le village d'à côté tout
juste débarqué de lampedusa ils sont
cinq ils arrivent de libye
il peut pas savoir qu'ils sont s'ils ont
des intentions malhonnêtes
la soirée semble calme rien à signaler
il n'y a personne
pas un chat dans la zone industrielle
personne non plus dans le quartier
résidentiel que ce prix le barça c'est
là gît là où a eu lieu le massacre a
personne ici à gauche
j'espérais que 90 savoir qu'une nuit de
roumains et un albanais sont rentrés
dans une maison pour avoir les clés de
la ville à vis des clés que les gardiens
n'avaient pas d'ailleurs ils ont été
massacrés sans tu te dis que c'est
impossible qu'il puisse arriver une
telle chose ici à gogo le massacre de
goal com c'était le 21 août 2007 un
couple de gardiens tué de façon barbare
par des immigrés la ligue du nord a
surfé sur cette histoire qui a choqué la
communauté l'avais dit aux forces de
l'ordre au préfet qu'on faisait les
réunions sur la sécurité avec d'autres
mères que le territoire était en train
de changer
on commençait à avoir des sales gueules
qui prenaient des cambriolages à
répétition dans les maisons c'était le
signal que quelque chose devait arriver
firmino vettori le maire de gaulle go
appartient à la ligue du nord
sa famille vit depuis des générations
dans ce village de 4000 habitants
avant on n'avait que quelques étrangers
et puis tout à coup il y en a eu un peu
trop
le village de gaulle go est au coeur de
la vénétie une région rurale où les
petites exploitations industrielles ont
remplacé les entreprises agricoles au
milieu des années 60
ce sont les terres de la ligue du nord
ce mouvement politique né en 1989 qui
défendent des idées identitaires et
régionaliste pour eux le nord riche
industriel doit arrêter de payer des
impôts pour financer le sud
le territoire des léguiste ce qu'ils
appellent la padanie est constitué de
neuf régions
au fil des années ce parti est devenue
toujours plus xénophobe et populiste
[Musique]
ce n'est pas possible de laisser aller
et venir ces barques dans la mer il faut
les coulées nous la padanie blanche et
chrétienne blanche et chrétienne nous
qui ne deviendront jamais islamistes
décomplexés les responsables de la ligue
du nord se distinguent par leurs
déclarations haineuses et leurs
dérapages racistes
qu'allons nous devenir le réceptacle de
toute l'afrique ou d'autres pays depuis
toujours ce parti prône l'indépendance
des régions du nord
la padanie et notre orgueil notre grande
ressource l'état italien à un compromis
la sérénité des futures générations de
la padanie en dilapidant notre argent
[Musique]
le sénateur au balto basse et leur
leader historique a toujours hurler à
ses fidèles la volonté d'une véritable
sécession de la padanie pour la ligue à
rome il n'y a qu'une bande de voleurs
qui pillent les ressources du nord le
nord qui produit 60% du pib italien
si la padanie existait vraiment elle
constituerait l'un des états les plus
riches d'europe
aujourd'hui la ligue du nord représente
près de 8% des électeurs italiens et
plus de 15 % dans certaines régions
[Musique]
c'est un allié incontournable pour
silvio berlusconi qui en a besoin pour
gouverner aux élections de 2008 pour
composer son nouveau gouvernement le
cavalière et lui donne quatre ministères
dont celui de l'intérieur
la ligue elle pour faire entendre sa
voix s'est rangé aux côtés du président
du conseil qu'elle a si souvent
discréditer les jeunes du nord continue
à être séduits par les propos du rebelle
taux bas aussi c'est à vous de jouer
maintenant place aux jeunes toujours
aussi populaire dans ses meetings
malgré une attaque cérébrale qui lui a
laissé des séquelles aujourd'hui le
leader ne parle plus de ces sessions
mais de fédéralisme fiscal c'est-à-dire
d'autonomie financière pour les
collectivités locales
bossi actuellement est l'homme politique
le plus intelligent d'italie c'est grâce
à lui que berlusconi tient toujours
debout
il le tient par les couilles c'est
réforme donne vraiment des résultats des
réformes qu'il ya encore vingt ou trente
ans n'étaient que des idées d'un groupe
d'illuminés
[Musique]
parmi les mesures phares prises par
l'allied la loi dite du paquet sécurité
qui donne plus de pouvoir au maire pour
sécuriser les villes et lutter contre
les clandestins comme ici à brescia une
ville industrielle à une heure de milan
avec près de deux cent mille habitants
c'est une des villes italiennes où il y
a le plus d'étrangers ici 20 % des
citoyens sont des immigrés la plupart
d'entre eux travaillent de façon
régulière dans les usines des alentours
la richesse qu'ils produisent chaque
année dans la ville est évalué à trois
milliards d'euros par an dans cette
usine de 130 salariés qui fabrique du
matériel d'isolation thermique 95% des
travailleurs sont des immigrés tous en
situation régulière
il ya longtemps les italiens venaient
travailler ici mais le travail n'est pas
facile alors ils venaient ils essayaient
et il partait mais les étrangers il y en
a très peu qui partent ils n'ont pas le
choix je dois travailler ici c'est de
pire en pire
on nous maltraitent comme des animaux
comme des animaux ils nous disent doigté
africains et étrangers ils t'envoient te
faire [ __ ]
ils nous cassent vraiment les pieds nous
on veut travailler on nous foute la paix
on en a assez de vivre cette situation
il a six ou qui le racisme existe
ok aucun étranger ne peut dire le
contraire à brèche même si les étrangers
sont une force de travail indispensable
la mairie multiplie les arrêter au style
est discriminatoire envers eux
une politique que ses représentants
assume ouvertement nicolas galitsios ali
et conseiller municipal c'est le porte
parole de la ligue du nord ici nous
sommes rendu compte que nous sommes
comme le peuple indien
ils ont subi l'immigration en
l'occurrence des européens
ils n'ont pas réagi ils se sont repliés
sur eux-mêmes j ai maintenant ils vivent
eux dans des réserves
on ne veut pas de ça on veut que notre
identité soit toujours reconnu nous
voulons être patron chez nous et qui
vient ti ci doit respecter nos règles
le programme électoral de la ligue du
nord était clair ici en 2008 contenir
l'invasion des étrangers et donc
compliquer les procédures
administratives pour obtenir des papiers
les aides sociales et les logements
publics fermés les camps de nomades et
empêcher l'ouverture de lieux de culte
musulmans
la ligue du nord a aussi sécurisé la
ville
ils ont renforcé le dispositif policier
est doublé les caméras de surveillance
voici l'exemple d'un parc municipal qui
était avons entre les mains de la petite
délinquance
notre système de prévention permet à
notre collègue de manoeuvrer les caméras
depuis la centrale opérationnelle
il peut zoomer pour aller voir les
personnes qu'ils sont assis sur les
bancs
il y annonce ce parc était recouvert de
bouteilles il y avait un usage exagéré
de boissons alcoolisées il ya qui
tiennent en mousse avec notre
réglementation nous avons interdit la
consommation d'alcool dans les parcs
aujourd'hui 120 t une caméra kadri tout
le territoire et bien sûr le dernier
camp de nomades a été placée sous haute
surveillance
la mairie s'est aussi attaqué au magasin
obtenu est fréquenté par les immigrés
des mesures discriminatoires qui ont
fait disparaître en trois ans 50% des
taxiphones de brescia iqbal et
pakistanais propriétaire d'une de ses
boutiques
il a dû la revendre je venais de
l'acheter et quelques mois plus tard la
loi est entrée en vigueur
j'ai fait des travaux demander les
toilets normale et celle pour les
handicapés ça m'a coûté vingt mille
euros
la loi impose et à ses commerces d'avoir
deux toilettes dont une pour les
handicapés et des cabines d'une certaine
taille des mesures absurdes qui n'était
pas exigé aux autres commerces tenus par
les italiens la ligue a tué cette
activité ne veulent pas que les immigrés
face du commerce que ce soit uniquement
de la main d'oeuvre des ouvriers qui a
ri travail rentrer dormir et le
lendemain on recommence
et c'est tout les taxiphones qui restent
doivent enregistrer les papiers
d'identité et les numéros d'appel de
tous leurs clients
mais comme les gens ne veulent pas être
fichés ils ne viennent plus téléphoner
anne les clients n'avaient pas laissé de
papier ils les avaient laissées mais
c'étaient des photocopies pas des
originaux j'ai eu cette amende de mille
30 euros chacune
les descentes de police sont de plus en
plus musclés quand ils viennent ils
ferment les portes à clé comme si les
gens allaient s'échapper avant c'était
pas comme ça maintenant
il ferme les deux entrées et contrôler
tout le monde un hard comme si les gens
étaient des criminels
cette loi sur les taxis fans a été
décrétée anticonstitutionnelle par le
conseil d'état
de même pour un arrêté qui prévoyait des
amendes contre les propriétaires de
restaurants de kebab si leur client
manger dans la rue
la ligue a aussi mis un point d'honneur
à interdire le jeu du cric et dans les
parcs municipaux le jeu favori des
jeunes pakistanais
on en a parlé avec la mairie et ils
n'ont jamais voulu nous donner un
terrain
nous sommes obligés de jouer ici et nous
avons pris des amendes de combien de 150
120 euros pourquoi on nous interdit de
jouer mais on veut jouer ici ils nous
ont toujours cassé les pieds
il continue à le faire et pourquoi à ton
avis j'en sais rien
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas de nous ils
ne veulent pas de nous c'est tous ces
jeunes ne comprennent pas toutes ces
interdictions et souffre de ce racisme
quotidien
[Musique]
le même soir dans un village des terres
padane la ligue organise un concours de
miss padanie pour élire celle qui
représentera le nord de l'italie
devant un jury trié sur le volet
composée de maires et d'élus locaux
martin a marqué zine se voir remettre le
prix de reine de beauté avec la mission
de défendre les traditions de sa région
[Musique]
moi je me sens avant tout pas d'âne même
si je ne sous estime pas les autres
populations mais je me sens pas d'âne
j'aime ma terre
dans ces régions la ligue est une force
incontournable
les échecs de berlusconi aux dernières
municipales et au référendum ont
fragilisé et l'alliance avec le
cavaliere
certains leaders de la ligue ne cachent
pas leur volonté de le laisser tomber
[Musique]